hey guys it's january twenty third I'm
chasidy and I've been thinking about
Star Wars Episode eight all day
everyone's freaking out what does the
last Jedi mean is Luke and adaiah no we
don't know anything plural for Jedi is
Jedi so yeah let's talk about the news
another nintendo switch launch game has
been confirmed and no it's not a waluigi
game I'm still waiting Square Enix has
confirmed that it's RPG I am setsuna
will be available for the switch at
release on March third I am setsuna is
the first game from Square Enix is
newest studio Tokyo RPG factory you play
as a young woman named setsuna who has
incredible power and inner strength the
turn-based game aims to offer controls
that our quote inspired by the Golden
Age of JRPGs I am setsuna is already
available on ps4 PS Vita and pc there
are now seven switch launch titles
confirmed for North America including
one to switch the binding of isaac
afterbirth plus just dance 2017 The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
Skylanders imagine aters and super
Bomberman are the switch launch lineup
could continue to grow between now and
release on March third so be sure to
subscribe and we'll keep you posted next
up will overwatch his chinese new year
event include a new mode a new leaked
video suggests over watches upcoming
chinese new year event will include a
new mode capture the flag the video
leaked on chinese social media site
Weibo appears to show the new mode along
with a bunch of new skins new limited
edition skins had previously emerged via
a leaked image after developer blizzard
announced the year of the rooster event
last week despite the rumors we know
little else about the event other than
its launch date January 24th a blizzard
spokesperson told polygon that the year
of the rooster event will be similar in
scope to past events like those themed
around Halloween and Christmas I can't
wait I just want those new skins finally
dishonor tues next big update is out now
and yes you can select a mission to
replay this on or tues big update
introduces a mission select option and
new difficulty settings among other
things the update is available today on
pc ps4 and xbox one it launched last
week in beta form on PC through steam
but today is the full official release
the new custom difficulty settings
include more than 20 sliders that
players can leverage to change things
like how many enemies might attack you
at once or how quickly sleep darts take
effect additionally there's an ultra
challenging difficulty mode called iron
in which there is no saving or loading
so when you die you're dead forever good
luck with that this new dishonor to
update also adds the much requested
ability to choose a specific mission to
replay all of your progress that you had
at the start of the mission including
your runes money and more will be intact
when you play the mission again today's
dishonor to patch also fixes a lot of
bugs and crash scenarios check out the
full patch notes on gamespot for more
and hey if you're a resident evil fan
you're excited for resident evil 7 be
sure to check out our GameSpot Studios
called reviving resident evil we talked
about how the series has changed video
games and also we talk to developers on
how it's influenced them so be sure to
check that out and subscribe and I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]